we use the t-38 for Space Flight
Readiness Training it's a supersonic jet
trainer that the Air Force initially
used this is the one thing that we do in
all of our training that really is not
simulated reading out of a book or
sitting in simulator it's never going to
be the same as when your hides on the
line when your decisions really have
consequences I would say it's the best
space flight training we have so it's a
jet we can fly solo but we typically
don't we typically use it again for the
Space Flight Readiness training mission
physiologically it's a challenge space
flight and be uncomfortable when you get
up there you might feel sick to your
stomach weightlessness is a big
challenge the view is incredibly
distracting so your body getting used to
all that that makes the t-38 a perfect
training environment
the initial airframe was built several
decades ago but it's blind like it's
brand-new or even better this t-38 is
decked out in a way that no other t-38
on the planet is so a fairly standard
layout in terms of aircraft the the
control stick here and then the
individual throttles for both motors on
the left side we've got a glass cockpit
here for a primary flight display we've
got electronic engine display here and
then we've also got our flight
management system which allows us to use
GPS technology for navigation and for
approaches it's got a 0-0 seat which
means that we can eject safely at zero
altitude and airspeed if we ever had an
had a need to do that essentially
there's dynamite and there something's
going to shoot you out like a rocket out
the top if you eject
so getting strapped in the to the
ejection seat is is not trivial this is
the ejection handle that you'd pull and
what that would do is it would start an
entire sequence and it would pull your
feet into a good position for ejection
at that point you're along for the ride
yeah right now 250 miles up is a Space
Station with six crew members on board
going 17,500 miles an hour over our
heads in orbit every day working on the
ISS is a there's a great story the whole
days full of problem-solving yes you're
in a research laboratory where it's a
punishing schedule we're doing research
hopping from experiment experiment all
day long but occasionally you have the
chance to actually look out the window
with the colleague of yours
every astronaut needs to be a crew
member on the t-38 whether that's a
front seat pilot or a back seat crew
member we all have the same tasks but
yeah everybody in the office flies the
t-38 I imagine that people who are going
to Mars are probably in grade school now
at this point so we're hoping to the lay
the foundation for what they're going to
need to do that do that well and do it
safely it's just really for me really
exciting just to be a part of that
machine and to contribute in any small
way to making sure that happens
you